thank God for the club they you know
thank you mom thank God for the oops
sorry sorry sorry
thank God for the voice memo thing that
we talked about a couple days ago I just
remembered a video that I desperately
wanted to do for my blog
garyvaynerchuk.com you're here you get
it um this numbers obsession game that
we're in this what I'm gonna call the
Twitter society that we live in where
people actually truly gauge their value
or somebody else's value on how many
Twitter followers they have somebody in
my own organization today said don't
don't worry it was a negative thing they
only had 40 something followers that is
not the way to play it this person's
awesome so I'm not throwing anybody
under the bus but that is not the way to
play it because I want you to understand
something it is not the number of emails
you have on your list or users that
follow you on Twitter or fans on
Facebook because I can build a four
million dollar business with four people
I don't understand from a business sense
why people think the number counts I
mean have you ever heard of the heavy
user have you do you understand the top
two to five percent a lot of times
completely wield the direction of your
company I really think you need to stop
taking the people you have for granted
and I think I've done a little bit of
that so this is a little bit of my own
little thing lately I've been in
emailing everybody who leaves a comment
on Wine Library TV I think you need to
understand that it's not getting more
numbers it's not number grabbing it's
understanding who you already have and
cultivating those relationships so
please it's not the number of people
that follow you on twitter
it's how passionate they are there's
plenty of people there's plenty of
people out there that have 4,000
followers but 3,000 of them will go
through fire for them well somebody else
has a hundred thousand and only two
hundred will go through fire for them
think about that understand that that is
a very substantial part of building a
real business it's just important that's
it it's all I got